este lago que está a mis espaldas es
famoso en la región de eslobians en el
don vast por los poderes curativos que
tiene el barro que está en su interior
históricamente los habitantes de esta
zona del país vienen hasta aquí a
ponerse ese barro especialmente en las
articulaciones o en lugares donde tienen
dolores en los músculos pero este año en
especial se ha convertido también en un
elemento curativo para la salud mental
no solamente de los habitantes de esta
región que tuvieron un invierno durísimo
por la falta de Electricidad y también
por los efectos de la guerra Esta es una
zona atacada constantemente por las
tropas rusas el frente de batalla está
Solamente 23 kilómetros de aquí el más
cercano y estas ciudades de alrededor
son atacadas permanentemente pero
también la población si bien Se ha
beneficiado de este lago está lleno de
mujeres hombres con sus niños también lo
es para los soldados muchos de ellos
vienen del frente de batalla vienen en
unidades se quitan los uniformes quedan
en ropa interior y van directamente a
refrescarse y a bañarse muchos de ellos
nos cuentan que llevan más de un año en
esta zona del país con solamente 10 días
de descanso Así que en medio de estas
dificultades la ministra viceministra de
defensa dicho que algunos de los
momentos más difíciles de la guerra en
este momento se viven aquí especialmente
en el frente de criminal Beethoven no
muy lejos de aquí allí las fuerzas rusas
presionan para romper las líneas de
defensa muchos de estos hombres combaten
allí pero en esos momentos de descanso
en el que tienen
oportunidad de salir del frente vienen
aquí a descansar y a bañarse en estas
aguas además para refrescarse un poco
ahora Que las temperaturas suben a más
de 30 grados centígrados